Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a South Korean
comedy film called “Slow Video.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts in a CCTV control center
where two women are talking about their new
young coworker.
He is wearing sunglasses indoors which the
women think is weird.
Suddenly, they detect two robbers on the run.
Their boss is notified and they quickly call
the police.
Everyone in the office tracks the robbers
through the cameras, and yet they get lost.
When they start losing hope, the new employee
shows them a clip of the robbers hiding in
an alleyway.
Because of his help, they are soon caught
by the police.
The employee’s name is Yeo Jang-boo and
he has a rare genetic condition that makes
him see everything in slow motion.
Using his disorder, he was able to see where
the robbers went even though they were moving
at a high speed.
When Jang-boo was in class five, he took part
in a relay race with his childhood crush Bong
Soo-mi.
That was when he first started to see things
in slow motion.
His parents took him to doctor Seok who diagnosed
him with dynamic visual acuity, a rare disorder
that enables him to visually perceive fine
detail in a moving object that ordinary people
cannot as if he's seeing the world in slow
motion.
To prove that Jang-boo in fact has the disorder,
the doctor throws a baseball at him at high
speed, which he catches with ease.
The doctor advises him to wear sunglasses
at all times for comfort.
After Jang-boo is diagnosed, his father flies
to a foreign country to earn money for his
treatment.
Jang-boo is left at home with his mother and
younger sister.
He claims that the disorder has been a blessing
and a curse at the same time.
Although he could watch the wind move women’s
skirts in slow motion, he was bullied in school
for his sunglasses.
His only friend then was Soo-mi who he started
to fall in love with.
But as time passed, Soo-mi got severely bullied
for being his friend and so, she left him.
Following that, Jang-boo has never had a friend.
He wanted to lose his eyesight altogether
so he watched TV all the time.
His vision didn’t really get worse but he
developed an obsession with k-dramas.
He learned all the social skills from the
actors in the drama but never got out of the
house to practice them.
His father refused to return to Korea even
during the holidays to save money.
But it all went to waste when one day he died
because of an accident in the workplace.
Following the death, the only man that Jang-boo
is close to is doctor Seok.
He advises him to see the world outside of
his room and help his family with money.
That is why Jang-boo starts to work in the
CCTV control center.
In a monologue, he claims that he likes to
watch people on the screen because it reminds
him of dramas, the only difference is that
in this drama, everyone is the lead actor.
His coworker, Byeong-soo talks to their boss
about Jang-boo’s behavior, claiming that
he is very introverted and doesn’t talk
to anyone.
He promises to take care of the guy because
he is a true talent.
Byeong-soo sits beside him at work and tries
talking to Jang-boo.
However, a shy Jang-boo answers all of Byeong-soo’s
questions in his head and doesn’t speak
to him.
While monitoring the cameras, he seems to
be counting how many steps people take to
reach a certain place.
Byeong-soo thinks it’s weird but doesn’t
ask any questions.
In an attempt to socialize with him, Byeong-soo
asks him if he has a girlfriend.
This reminds Jang-boo of Soo-mi, so he goes
to her house the very next day.
Soo-mi has grown up into a beautiful woman
but with financial issues.
Her debt collector nags her to sell the house
to pay back her loans.
Jang-boo watches her from afar but is too
scared to go talk to her.
That day onwards, he watches her through the
CCTV cameras every day and memorizes her daily
routine.
At night she drinks soda in front of a coffee
shop, so he, too, does the same.
He sees her eyeing an abandoned sofa on the
way and drags it in front of the coffee shop
the next day.
Soo-mi notices the sofa but doesn’t think
much of it.
The following day, she is stuck at a bus stop
because of heavy rainfall.
Jang-boo sees this on the monitor and goes
to help her with Byeong-soo.
He puts the umbrella over her like in the
k-dramas but Soo-mi calls him a creep and
walks away.
Following that, the two go to doctor Seok
asking for ways Jang-boo could impress Soo-mi.
He suggests Jang-boo give her flowers.
Soo-mi is late for her musical drama audition
the next day.
She calls the manager and starts singing in
the middle of the road as her audition.
As she sings a beautiful song, the bystanders
watch her in awe.
Jang-boo also arrives there with a bouquet
of flowers.
He hands her the flower after the song but
Soo-mi doesn’t appreciate it.
She tells him she would rather prefer a box
of ramen and walks away.
Jang-boo calls her name and finally introduces
himself as her childhood best friend.
But she claims that her name is Oh Soo-mi
and not Bong Soo-mi.
It turns out Jang-boo has been following the
wrong woman all this time, yet he has started
to fall for her deeply.
That evening, they accidentally bump into
each other and Soo-mi makes Jang-boo carry
her groceries.
Before leaving, Soo-mi asks him why he is
looking for Bong Soo-mi to which he replies
that he used to like her in school.
The next day at work, Jang-boo sees Soo-mi
receive a phone call on the monitor.
The person on the other end informs her that
she got a role in the musical.
She jumps and dances in the streets as Jang-boo
watches her on the screen.
That night, Soo-mi goes to celebrate at a
local roadside restaurant.
She notices Jang-boo watching her from outside
and invites him in.
As they talk, she shows him the musical’s
script and practices her lines.
Jang-boo compliments her acting and shows
her a talent of his own.
Soon, the entire restaurant watches Jang-boo
catch spoons thrown at him.
The following day, Jang-boo walks around Soo-mi’s
neighborhood while counting his steps.
Byeong-soo sees him doing this and realizes
he is trying to memorize the ways.
While returning home, Soo-mi finds Jang-boo
waiting for her.
They walk together talking about several things.
She asks him what his job is and finds out
that he works at the CCTV center and can watch
people all day.
They stop in front of the cafe that Soo-mi
always stares at.
She reveals that she has a crush on the cafe’s
owner and gushes about him owning a car.
A jealous Jang-boo stares at the owner for
a long time.
He has made up his mind to take her on a ride
to impress her.
He asks everyone at work if they own a car
in hopes of borrowing it.
However, none of them happen to own one.
While returning home, Soo-mi is approached
by the debt collector.
He starts to yell at her and threatens to
hit her if she doesn’t return the money.
Jang-boo and Byeong-soo arrive there right
on time and save her from the man.
When Jang-boo returns to work, Soo-mi yells
thank you to one of the cameras, knowing that
he is watching on the other end.
At the end of the day, they meet at a park
and talk for a long time.
Jang-boo asks her what she would do if she
owned a car to which Soo-mi says that she
would drive to the sea every day.
Since he cannot get a car, Jang-boo befriends
his local bus driver by traveling with him
all day.
He had been watching the driver play baseball
alone at night through the cameras.
At the end of the day, Jang-boo joins him
for a game and asks him for a favor.
Byeong-soo, the bus driver, and Jang-boo pick
up Soo-mi from the bus stop the next day and
make their way to Busan to visit the sea.
Seeing his efforts to make her happy, Soo-mi
starts to like Jang-boo.
However, their bus is stopped by the border
police who don’t allow the local district
bus to enter the other district.
An angered Soo-mi tries to fight the policeman
while Byeong-soo calms her down.
Their effort is useless because at the end
of the day, they have to return home without
reaching the sea.
Jang-boo’s boss tells them about recent
cases of women being abducted around the town
and asks them to be on high alert at all times.
Just then, Jang-boo notices Soo-mi on a monitor
but she disappears right after.
He freaks out and rushes to see if she is
okay only to see that she was trying to prank
him to see if he will come.
Soo-mi takes off his glasses for the first
time and the two finally kiss.
Jang-boo takes Soo-mi home and she invites
him in.
However, their plans are ruined when Soo-mi
notices the debt collectors in her house.
They throw her belongings around threatening
her to return the money.
Jang-boo tries to run to her but suddenly
falls down as his vision goes blurry.
After the men leave, Jang-boo and Soo-mi sit
down to talk.
In the pile of stuff that the collectors threw
out are drawings that Jang-boo made for Soo-mi
when they were in school.
Soo-mi reveals that she lied to him about
being a different girl because she didn’t
want to be compared to her younger self.
Jang-boo keeps quiet the whole time as Soo-mi
looks at the drawings while smiling.
He visits doctor Seok the next day, informing
him that his eyes have gotten blurry.
It turns out that with time, his disorder
has gotten worse, because of which he will
be losing his vision very soon.
Jang-boo had known that he would eventually
go blind one day, that is why he has been
counting steps everywhere he goes, so it would
be easier for him when he loses his vision
entirely.
While Jang-boo is troubled by his worsening
vision, Soo-mi is worried about her debt.
She sells her house and gathers enough money
to pay her creditors back but now, she has
nowhere to live.
Jang-boo watches her on screen while she talks
to a shopkeeper with a box of her belongings.
Suddenly, his coworker notices a car suspiciously
circling the same area.
She looks closely at its number plate and
notices that the car belongs to a kidnapper
on the run.
She notifies the boss and the police are informed
immediately.
However, they lose sight of the car and at
the same time, Jang-boo loses sight of Soo-mi.
He freaks out and runs to save her from potential
danger.
On his way, he loses his vision completely
and crashes the bike.
Byeong-soo notices this through the cameras
and runs to help him.
Soo-mi, on the other hand, is approached by
a strange man who grabs her arm.
But before he can take her away, Jang-boo
starts to run towards them.
The abductor runs away but Jang-boo almost
crashes into a bus.
The police arrive and take Soo-mi in for interrogation.
Now, Jang-boo is left alone in the streets
and is helped by Byeong-soo.
He cries while holding his friend, devastated
on losing his vision.
Several days have passed since the incident.
Soo-mi gets busy with her life and doesn’t
contact Jang-boo.
She looks at the CCTV cameras often when she
misses him.
A few months later, she notices Jang-boo inside
her favorite cafe.
She happily approaches him and waves her hand
but is shocked when Jang-boo brings out his
stick and walks the other way.
She follows him around the town and finally
reaches an art gallery that is filled with
paintings of her that Jang-boo has drawn.
In a monologue, Jang-boo says that he has
lost his vision but he still remembers her.
The next day, Soo-mi again follows him but
this time, he asks her where she wants to
go.
She realizes that he can sense her and the
movie ends as the two hug.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.